[Music]
and video of women and children and
teenagers that have been AB abducted
from their family members and they are
forced into being Muslims and they are
forced to marry men of Muslim faith and
they are force of having children
throughout the men and their parents
have no idea in any way whatsoever what
happened to their children they are
going to the police department and the
police department gives them nonsense of
an answer because they are run by the
Sharia government and they are
supporting all the action that are
taking place in Egypt on now on the
Christmas Eve the public Christmas Eve
of January 6 a m took place after the
Christmas night they killed 16 Angel and
they have abused them in the worst way
possibly physically they have mutilated
their bodies they cut them into pieces
and their only crime was that they are
Christian I also have have heard of a
Muslim mother asking her child uh not
old enough to be in first grade what do
you think of the Christians and um um
Jewish people the answer was they are
pigs and dogs and they are the answer
and then she asked them another question
why do you think we hate these people
because they are infs and unbel
[Music]
[Applause]
the the
question in the place they everywhere
they go they but what is the question
the question is why you are forcing
people into Islam who they don't want to
be why are
youing the young girls from their
families and you are mesing them and
raping them and
[Music]
it
is that Egypt is not planed by the sh
and anybody Robert knows that very well
and anybody who's coming to Islam and
has a minimum amount knowledge about the
Muslim world knows very well that Egypt
is
the
robt this is this is number this is
number this
is and by the way we don't have any
intention to
apply answer
question not
not the agenda of
mass any Islamic organization to apply
in the United States okay we're going to
move to the next question
[Music]
next
question and I'd like to know the M
estate
[Music]
AG e a master I didn't get e a master
master master
[Music]
I got Robert gave
Robert
[Music]
yes do you AG with this every T past
present living in day was Meed by
who came out of a
m
no not come from the
[Applause]
[Music]
M that's our answer
if you
answer they uh my name is Roy please be
with us my question is directed to
Muhammad uh the United States was
started as a religious Refuge but over
the years uh
we we've gotten worse more of it so
we're really not the nation we started
with since the beginning of man there
would be many wars and uh starting from
Mahari of the way that man should live
and get along with each other my
question is do you think that Sharia is
a suitable candidate for the peace among
men Nations and your reason for for
saying
so no no no no I want you to answer
I can you repeat the question sir oh I
yes I can yes please all right from the
beginning of America we were religious
Haven for Religious Freedom yes over the
years America Has Fallen
morally since the beginning of time
starting with the wars of
Mahari man has come up with many wars
and systems my question to you is do you
think that Sharia is a suitable
candidate to promote peace and love and
compassion among men and Nations and why
is what what reasons do you have with
your answer okay I do believe the
Islamic law the Shar law pro peace
between the Nations it is the verse in
the Quran said that God will not never
you or encourage you to hate one
another that's absolutely true the the
message Islam is the message of Peace
The Message of Islam the Islam itself
care about animals and dogs the care the
Islam care about animal and God there is
a
tradition one of the of prophet Muhammad
sahu Ali him that he is not a Believer
who sleep with a full stomach and his
mother his neighbor with in
so my my answer to your question is Shar
PR peace Shar PR cooperation sh
collaboration between people that's my
answer I appreciate your very much i'
like follow question in the logo of your
Muslim American society you have a pan
and you have Crossed Swords what is the
meaning of the Cross swords there is
there is nothing there sir the symbol of
mess is is the uh cross and the uh
United States of America I know but I
didn't add what is the the significance
of the C the cross swords there is
nothing there is nothing in Mass symbol
sir there is nothing in Mass symbol I'll
show you the I'll show
you the logo is here this is the logo of
mass it is mass with the chrisan and the
two uh South American North America so
if you had a choice between man having
you know government of uh de democracy
or republican would you choose would you
choose Sharia law over democracy
democracy is part of the
Shar thank
you my name is Joan and I have one very
simple question for the Muslim americ
Society I was on the phone this morning
with the FBI and I would like to know
why the masas is on the watch list for
[Music]
[Applause]
terrorism listen to me listen to me I
want you to check the list of terrorist
organization in the United
States is not terorist organization if
you need your information I don't need
your information I want the truth and
from your you three very honest men you
are not telling them that is you are
telling me the FBI is L
for my name is not sister brother my
name is
[Applause]
know and I said I said earlier that the
executive director was invited by the
department of Home Security in last this
last to attend a meeting with other
leaders we everybody in this country is
innocent I believe I'm proving guilty
you need to bring F you need to BR f
I invite everyone here to please contact
the
[Applause]
fpr
[Music]
[Applause]
the
my you
mention you mentioned the
[Music]
okay I cannot give you the exact number
but I tell you I'll tell you what it is
I'll tell you what it is I gave St
Island in June
1998 I was one of the founders of the
most and 3075 Richmond we started there
Friday prayer attended by 40 people
right now 1500 attend Friday
[Applause]
pray the annual pray which is the prayer
after the end of Ramadan the fight in St
Island they have instead of scheduling
one prayer they scheduled three prayers
nine
to accommodate the people in the
community that's I don't have an exact
number as I said but I this is a sign to
give you how much the Muslim Community
is growing in thank
[Applause]
you question is you said that most of
them how you to have
Community how many you to
how many how many hous how many house
family yeah how many do you
toing how many people will be attending
that that place it based on the number
which is certified by the department of
building if the occupancy of the
building 100 people 100 people will
attend if it's 150 it's 150 whatever
capacity of the place is that we abided
by the policy and R of the
state what's your question okay we have
this on I I I ask how many Muslim
families going to be served in in this
area in of Northern Area that was the
question how many families you mean in
South in Midland Beach and South Beach
yeah hundreds I would say thousands I
would say thousands I can please raise
your hand who look
[Music]
thank
you hi good evening my name is Donna F I
will not talk about religion because
that's not my question I don't even live
in this neighborhood I happen to live in
grasia what I want to talk about is the
saturation and residential neighborhoods
of buildings that are Grand fared into
the building called
and a saturated residential areas with
parking no parking people lit I
experienced it in my neighborhood with
do offices the war from the 1950s when
the doctors lived upstairs and they took
care of their patients and they went
right down from their residence the war
is being changed with doctor offices and
preschools and schools in residential
areas not have resentment with the
residents in the area when they can't
come home from work and
[Applause]
talk the the the
place the most croud time of the place
will be FR and two blocks two blocks we
have M each
parking you know
ality we all want to park close to where
we're going we don't want to walk 6:00
in the rain or snow and what about the
other activities that are going to go on
the Friday night
prayer come walk
not I our community pray they can Mar by
the beach and they can walk with a who
can them I
understand old scenario of you know
taking 10 lb of baloney in a 5 lb a it's
not going to work it's not going to fit
that building was knocked down or any
footprint of that building is changed
then the parking zoning goes in and Mr
angler can uh you know certify that that
means that if that building is knocked
down or the footprint of that building
is changed in any way the new zoning
takes place which means that one parking
has to be put in for 10 people each of
10 people so unfortunately this building
was built in the 50s it fell within the
old it does not require
par of course create
problem hospital but that's the way the
building is
[Music]
[Applause]
not